Visualization is a crucial step
for initial data exploration.
It helps us discern
relationships, patterns,
and outliers.
This video will give
us a starting point
on how to make plots in R, but
more advanced and way cooler
visualization tips will be
given in Week 8 of this class.
Let us first create a
scatterplot with Protein
on the x-axis and
Fat on the y-axis.
To do this we can use
the plot function in R
and give it as a first input the
Protein vector on the x-axis,
and as a second input the
TotalFat vector on the y-axis.
And now pressing Enter,
a new window pops up.
If you are on a PC, the new
Windows is called R Graphics,
and if you are on a Mac
it is called Quartz.
The plot has a very
interesting triangular shape.
It looks like foods that
are higher in protein
are typically lower in
fat, and vice versa.
Now, looking at the
aesthetics of the graph,
we realize that R
gives default names
for the x-axis and the y-axis
using the vector dollar
notation.
Now we can modify these labels
by adding more arguments
to the plot function.
To go back to the R
console, you can simply
switch windows using
the Control tab
if you are on a Windows machine.
On a Mac, the windows are
not overlaid by default,
so accessing the
console should be easy.
OK, now let's use the Up
arrow to go back to our plot
function, and add the
argument xlab = "Protein"
and that gives us the
label of the x-axis.
Then ylab = "Fat" and this gives
us the label to the y-axis.
And let's add a title to the
plot using the argument main,
say the title is
"Protein vs Fat".
And let's change
the color to red.
And remember to
put quotation marks
around the values of
all these arguments.
And now pressing Enter and going
back to the graphics window,
we see that R made all the
modifications we requested.
Another way we can visualize our
data is by plotting histograms.
We can do this using the
histogram function in R,
but note that this
function now only takes
one variable as an input,
because the y-axis should
have the frequencies.
So let's go back to
our console and create
a histogram of
VitaminC, for instance.
So we're going to use the
hist function, or histogram.
And then the argument that it
takes is the VitaminC vector.
Let's label the
x-axis as "Vitamin C",
and this is given
to us in milligrams.
And give it a title,
say "Histogram
of Vitamin C Levels".
Hmm.
Even though the maximum
vitamin C content
is 2000 milligrams,
most of our foods--
well, to be more precise,
more than 6,000 of them--
have less than 200
milligrams of vitamin C.
And the histogram lumps them
all together in one cell.
Well, it would be nice if we
can zoom into this section
here and get a finer
understanding of the data.
To do this we need to limit
the x-axis to go from zero
to, say, 100 milligrams.
So let's go back to the
console, and then we're
going to add the argument
xlim to limit the x-axis.
And using the combine
function or the c function,
we're going to set
the first input
to be 0, which is the
lowest value that we want
to see on the x-axis, and the
second argument as being 100,
which is the highest value that
we want to see on the x-axis.
And now pressing
Enter, and we can
see that R gives us 0
to 100 on the x-axis.
But we only see
this one big cell.
It seems that R only
zoomed into the area,
but it didn't break
that huge cell,
and this doesn't give us
any additional information.
So we really need to break up
the cell into smaller pieces.
And say we want 100 cells,
and since the interval
goes from 0 to 100,
then we would expect R
to create divisions that are
one milligrams in length.
So let's do this.
Let's go back to the
console, and then we're
going to add the
argument breaks = 100
and this sets the
number of cells
that we want to see to 100.
So let's see.
Oh.
We actually only see
five cells, and each cell
is 20 milligrams long.
Well, what happened?
We were expecting 100 cells.
Well remember that the
histogram originally
went far beyond 100 milligrams.
The maximum was 2000 milligrams.
And now if we were to divide
the original interval from 0
to 2000 into 100 cells,
then 2000 divided by 100,
each cell would be
20 milligrams long.
And this is exactly what R did.
It actually divided all
of the spectrum of values
from 0 to 2000 into
100 cells, and not only
the spectrum from 0 to 100.
But we still want to divide
the interval 0 to 100
into 100 cells, each
of length 1 milligram.
And how can we do this?
Well, we simply need
to think in terms
of the original interval,
which was 0 to 2000.
And if we were to break
it into 2000 cells,
then each one will be
of length one milligram.
So now we know that
actually we needed
to set the breaks to 2000.
So let's do this.
And now we obtain our
refined histogram.
And we see new
information here come up.
Remember our initial conclusion
was that more than 6,000 foods
have less than 200
milligrams of vitamin C.
But now that we
refined our graph,
we obtained an additional
level of information.
Actually, more
than 5,000 of them
have less than one
milligram of vitamin C.
Now a third way we can visualize
the data is using box plots.
So let's go back to the
console and create a box plot
for sugar.
So the function we're going
to be using is simply boxplot,
and similarly to the
histogram function,
the boxplot function only takes
as an input a single vector.
And in this case it would
be the Sugar vector.
And let's create a title that
says "Boxplot of Sugar Levels".
And is it the
y-axis or the x-axis
that we have to label
it as the sugar level?
So if we're not so sure,
let's just plot it,
and, oh, this should
be the y-axis.
So let's go back to
the console, and simply
set the y label
to be "Sugar (g)".
And now we have our box
plot with the right labels.
What is it trying
to tell us here?
It looks a little bit strange.
Well, the average of
sugar across the data set
seems to be pretty low.
It's somewhere
around five grams.
But we have a lot of outliers
with extremely high values
of sugar.
There exist some foods that
have almost 100 grams of sugar
in 100 grams.
Well, candies are definitely
among these foods.
So we just reviewed
three ways in which
we can visualize our data.
In Week 8, we will see more
advanced visualization tools
to make more informative plots.
In our next video we will see
how we can construct and add
new variables to our data set.